it's government to protect at least 30%
of them by 2030 from industrial fishing
mining and drilling the Environment
Secretary Michael Gove is told Sky News
that Lewis has shown inspirational
leadership and grit
so Lewis's journey began on the 12th of
July at Lands End in Cornwall he headed
straight from lizards point it's
treacherous waters were his first major
challenge after a brief stop in his
hometown of Klim ahthe Lewis took
advantage of the unusually hot weather
but as the weather took a turn for the
worse at Dungeness so did his optimism
as he got stuck and had to change course
finally making it around on his third
attempt well now he's on the home
straight and aims to reach us here at
the finish line in just over an hour's
time if he does he'll do it in 49 days
that is one day less than he planned
Pierre then is his highs and his loads
I don't think I've done one swim in 31
years where somebody hasn't come up
before home and said this swimmers
impossible you will never ever make it
and it's not I'm going out there to
prove them wrong
but there is a certain satisfaction at
the end when you do achieve and you say
yeah that is possible he can start
pushing the boundaries of human
endurance he's gonna have to tackle the
freezing cold water also the possibility
of sunburn of course is going to swallow
a huge amount of sea water and there he
goes
[Music]
on the corner over there is not quite
it's one of the most dangerous places in
the whole of UK waters loads and loads
and loads of jellyfish you've been stung
yet yep one hour Trevor 3k yesterday we
were coming six days at that time go for
it guys look out now the North Pole and
you just can't convey what's actually
happening in the water swimming sideways
something is the only sport where you're
rotating on three axes
the pain is there there I've covered
nearly 500 kilometres some lands in and
we've been stuck over here of Dungeness
the final Cape for two days determine
now some time to get around this point
and once I'm around this point then
we're on the homestretch
[Music]
yeah most of us don't fancy that let's
see if one person does form a
competitive swimmer Mark Foster who
represented Great Britain in the
Olympics and elsewhere obviously a five
Olympic Games throwdown
do you fancy that it looks horrific as
far as I'm concerned doesn't it just
gotta go around the whole of the UK
looks horrendous I must have it when we
got here earlier it looked quite calm in
the water and we were getting battered
up here so I think the thing is we both
said we'd rather be in well I said I'd
rather be in there than here yeah but
know what it's done is amazing
Brendan's forty miles I mean I used to
swim an awful lot as a kid up and down a
swimming pool but you don't take in the
elements for example like the jellyfish
which I have to say because of the jelly
fish blooms that are there from the
environment environmental why there are
so many jellyfish in the sea nowadays
because we're taking all the fish out
and the fish were one of the ones that
actually a jellyfish before but we've
opened a similar story of talk to when
we were a child and at ten years of age
I'm in watching jaws and I got paranoid
about swimming in the sea because I
thought Jules is in there waiting for me
I still do thirty-five years later but
all the jellyfish stings the physical
exertion and the mental side of things
there's an awful lot of fun that's
making us so so difficult there and all
of this looks horrific I have to say but
the headlands the currents the swells
the the sea states have all been very
problematic for him you freestyle was
one of the strokes you did Frank rule
for those of us who aren't professionals
and he talks about cork skiing in the
water as he swims because of the swell
and just keeping fat is really difficult
can you understand it talk us through
this sort of the physiology of that
ocean water swimmer by any stretch of
the imagination but when you talk about
all your power comes from your hips
anyway in your core so what generally
what you are doing when you ask them and
you ask something from side to side and
I think when you are in the sea what
you're trying to do is make every stroke
as long as possible so therefore you're
gonna take less strokes when you're
swimming in the sea you can't do a
normal what I would say Paul stroke
because obviously your arms and top of
the surface their arms have been knocked
around an awful lot that's what you tend
to do is put your arm in a little bit
deeper that's what she it's a little bit
more I don't have it to see that
whatsoever I can't see what I'm doing
but just to try and make things a little
bit easier on your body and that's it's
all about trying to maintain your stroke
as we found out here for 50 days you
know you're getting in the water after a
long day swimming on your saw and your
point is an activity of mind snapping
we've got to go again so it's about how
you replenish yourself not only what
you're doing afterwards at the same time
and we saw there some of the images have
been being massaged because without a
support network he won't be able to be
able to do what he's doing he set off
already his support vessel has take him
to the start line but just the
difficulty for him as the the distance
wom and the and the actual position he
needs to be in because of the current
server things they have to be very
specific about taking him back to where
he he was meant to be to make sure he
does indeed swim the channel properly
but in terms of the calories he burns
900 calories an hour 10,000 a day he
says he has a very active mind when he's
in the water though no you said to me
used to do 20 kilometer swims in one day
yeah his average she was a virgin he
hoped ten kilometres sometimes it had to
be more and obviously less because of
the weather sometimes but the active
might how'd you talk to yourself while
you're doing someone said it to me and I
guess lots of you do take yourself to
different places I mean there was a lot
of time I used to sing in my head I was
really really good by the way
it used to go through stuff that used to
do at school
the penny mine was a school you know I'm
talking about nine to fifteen years of
age so I'd go about working things out
and sometimes used to go to a really
really weird place was my head was like
a cabin of a plane where I was the pilot
the plane and Oz I had passengers on
board and I think you set yourselves to
lots of different places so you need to
because obviously it's me up and down
when you are in pain and you know you've
got a distance or you've got a set to do
as it was for me
you need to sort of switch your mind up
from what you're doing because otherwise
you're going to god this is playing for
us a long way so you've got to have
positive thought rather than negative
not surprising and in terms of talking
to himself the chef his chef on board
says that he's prone to a bit of
Battenberg he needs to take 10,000
calories a day in that's supposed to be
three jacket potatoes when he finishes
swimming and occasionally he shouts out
thoughts for his blog that he's been
writing for Sky News occasion he would
just shout out that he wanted back you
better get the end so they all had to
have the backing both in the victorious
sponge ready which is not quite what was
the intention in terms of his diet I
think anyway 10,000 calories a day is a
lot certainly so we saw the pictures
then of Lewis getting into support
though this morning just beforehand he
spoke to my colleague Jonathan Samuels
I'm so I'm so excited excited and
relieved there's been an enormous Lee
long swim as you say we've been on here
for 49 days we've been at sea for 49
days I also wasn't sure when I when I
started at Lands End whether I would be
able to make it you know the world is
divided between pioneers and followers
pioneers do not know whether they're
going to be successful in their quest
I hoped I prayed that I could do it I
did the training to do it but still it's
an awful long way and anything could
have happened over those 50 days
well our science correspondent Thomas
Moore is the man with the best view of
all of this he is on the support float
that will follow Lewis pews every stroke
and he's with Lewis now they took the
boat from Dover marina within the last
hour to head out to those exact
coordinates we were talking about of
when Lewis finished his last bit of the
swim yesterday and that's where he'll
start from today in under 30 minutes
time and Thomas I know you've swung with
him you know how hard this is but he
must breathe pretty chipper despite the
weather at very nearly getting to the
end of this yeah absolutely Anna he is
in a good mood because he is so close to
adrenaline of course lifts any any kind
of depression you might have when you're
faced with these conditions we're half a
mile off off the cliffs here were just
west of Dover and look who we found
there is Lewis there is his support boat
the Aquila in exactly the rain fact you
can just see him in his speedo is just
emerging from below deck there there he
is stripped off he's got a swimming cap
on the white cap and he looks pretty
ready to go so quite extraordinary that
in these conditions he's actually going
to go for it but then perfectly honest
the water's probably warmer than the air
yes and certainly at Thomas yes
certainly Thomas we've been talking
about how awful it is to be outside best
to be in the water because the sea state
is pretty good compared with some of the
terrible conditions he swam in and
forcing himself to swim in order to keep
to this deadline of 50 days
yes certainly I mean the the the
conditions matter now there are small
waves out here in the channel and
probably about 20 to 25 centimeters but
you can see there that he's prepared to
go in and he has swum in pretty wild
conditions over the last last few weeks
he talks about this being a swim in two
stages the first half up to from
Cornwall all the way up to the Isle of
Wight they were fairly benign very flat
seas very warm excellent weather but
since the Isle of Wight has been really
difficult going in fact in the gloom out
there is Dungeness where the nuclear
power station is and that was a headland
the last headland before he got hit over
and it took him three days to get round
the tide really didn't work in his favor
he had some it's in really rough
conditions and he was really hard going
but now he is so close you can see him
there on the stern of the Aquila this
rain is obviously not going to help him
but been perfectly honest I didn't think
anything is going to skid get in his way
now at the last last two three miles
today though are we waiting from Thomas
are we gonna see him dive in
it's it that's a good question I think
they're just trying to find the GPS
coordinates what happens is that to
follow the the rule set by the channel
swimming Association you have to mark
the precise coordinates of where he
finished his last swim and that is the
point that he has diving and continue so
there is this long continuous chain that
goes all the way from Land's End to
Dover here and what happens is that
Steve and the skipper will motor in the
right direction towards Dover and at the
right point he'll give the count three
two one swim ago and that's when Lewis
will jump in now we've been told that it
could be three minutes until Lewis gets
in we're going to try and reposition
ourselves and there to try and give you
the best shot and you might want to come
back to us in a couple of years time
we'll do just that thomas moore thank
you very much indeed so stand by Lewis
Pugh is about to take the final of his
swimmers on day 49 well joining me now
is a man who wanted to reach the same
finish line as Lewis I'm already looking
at you sympathetically I have to say
Haven well she's the only another
swimmer to have attempted it didn't
quite make it more in that in a moment
also here with me is someone who can
maybe tell us how it might be possible
to put your body and your mind through
what Lewis has done and succeed Greg
white teachers celebrities about the art
of endurance and is a physical activity
expert apologies to you in a moment
let's go straight back Lewis Pugh has
entered the water and he is off the
final part of swimming for kilometers to
go he told Thomas yesterday that he's
absolutely ready for this Thomas pitches
yeah I know we're trying to position
ourselves out here in some pretty rough
conditions Lewis is now in the water you
can see him making steady progress then
he'll be following the line all the way
back to Dover he's got a very steady
stroke when I was swimming with him the
other other week
really impressed how steady his pace was
it is a style which he's perfected over
over the years of swimming in these
conditions and there you can see his
white hat he wears a white hat with the
UN Environment logo on it and he likes
to swim alongside the boat that's where
Steven the skipper likes to keep him
because these are dangerous waters there
have people people who die while trying
to cross over to France and they do like
to keep a very close eye on him
as he's making his way alongside the
boat there and tell us about how he
deals with the temperature of the water
Thomas yeah I mean and he's used to much
colder temperatures this when I put him
up in the Arctic last year he was
swimming along the edge of the Arctic
ice pack and the temperature there was
minus 0.7 degrees and he swum in it for
23 minutes the temperature the water
here is about 18 19 warmer than usual
because the very hot summer that we've
had so that's to his benefit but it is
very thick layer of fat around him is
that's what open water swimmers tend to
do to build up that fat layer it
provides them with insulation so the
simple exercise of swimming means that
they retain that body heat for much
longer and in fact when I was in the
water it didn't feel that cold he's a
lot than I am so he would just won't
feel it even if he's swimming for two or
three hours I'm just reading from his
blog a Thomas that we've obviously been
covering here on sky and he said on day
43 this close to the end of the swim I
can honestly say that I am the most
physically and mentally exhausted that
I've ever been from such prolonged lack
of sleep injury consecutive days of hard
swimming and campaigning he expected it
mentally at least to get easier and
found that it had not I know Dungeness
and getting over that last 9th headland
was very difficult for him
but this has been making no bones about
it a real slog hasn't it yes it has and
he called this the Everest of swimming
when he started off in in Lands End and
he did that because it is a huge
challenge if you if you take there the
mountaineering analogy further Dungeness
Peninsula was that final ice wall before
the summit that he needed to overcome
now he's so close to the summit it's
much easier and he will plant his flag
and set a record today put his name down
in history as the first person to go
from Lands End
all the way to today that and it is a
phenomenal achievement speaking to other
channel swimmers they are full of
admiration because they know how tough
it is to be out here how lonely it is
and he does have a support boat and they
have been a huge motivator for him but
nevertheless but he's in the water
staring down into the gloom is
disorientating you lose all sense of of
sight sound it sense through deprivation
and it is a mental challenge then to
keep going when your body is hurting and
somewhere you need to find that inner
strength to keep going and make it to
the finishing line and that is what he
has done and we're standing right by it
ready to welcome him Tomas will let you
chase him down he's going faster than
you are right now Tomas more thanks very
much indeed so let's return them to my
guest sir Hayden Welch and Greg white so
we would get a talk with you about the
fact that you didn't quite make what
Luis is about to achieve how far did you
get - when did you try what was the
experience like I started from here so
my destination was in fact the other end
of the English Channel
I spent a hundred hours swimming and got
as far as Portland before my my swim
ended and then we had a week of gales
and the continuity was spoiled I ran out
of time and I'm just decided the
experiment was over and what was it
actually like for you in the water the
older days of swimming
that was fantastic I have to say you
know the English Channel can be the most
beautiful place when when you swim
through the day and the Sun start
setting it sends a glitter path of
sparkles all across the water it makes
you feel you could swim along that path
till morning but it can also be brutal
you know it's quite fitting today that
we have this weather for Louis to
finishing because this is the weather
we're we get used to be trained in it we
enjoy it it's tough it's hard but the
beauty of long-distance swimming is
wonderful I have to say the sea state is
fine for him today compared with what no
doubt you experienced and what he
experienced he of course did it the
other way around what you did was go
straight into the busiest shipping lane
in the world by tonnage and have all the
murky water he started in Cornwall
albeit with lots of jellyfish from
marine life sometimes dolphin pods
swimming alongside him to keep him going
but he had blue water that he could see
in you think this is part of the point
he's making this is the urban water
we've got here and this is the colour it
ends up there's part of the message he's
trying to bring back it's this colour
this this dark greeny brownie muddy
color from here all the way to Portland
it was for me I saw my hands in front of
my in front of my face
and very rarely for anything else Greg
white it's your job to get people in the
right mentality to do this sort of thing
first of all what knowest is achieved is
incredible I mean it is a war of
attrition and it's interesting what he
was just talking about this what you
have to remember is that the Lewis
started in glory of sunshine in
wonderful weather and as time has gone
on it's got worse and worse and worse of
course what that has done is that Trent
his physical state and his mental state
so he's got more fatigued as the
weather's got worse
psychologically started to question
himself as the weather's got worse so it
has got much more difficult for him as
time has gone on so to get this far is
incredible
and there's no doubt about it given his
tenacity and what he's achieved so far
he will
so how important is goal-setting and in
fact he has tuned one is to finish and
the fishing conditional is just there
secondly it is to get his message across
about getting governments to get inspire
to protect the oceans and marine
protected areas how big an impact does
that have
mentally I'm making his body and his
mind do stuff which it really doesn't
want to do what do you know it's
absolutely crucial
I mean firstly the goal setting is
absolutely key
and of course Louis's goal was to finish
here on Shakespeare Beach but actually
it's that daily goals is to short-term
goals that have really mattered what you
have to consider is that that we
consider 10 kilometers of swimming a
marathon so really what you're thinking
about he's doing a mouth and every
single day but he's doing on a very
small muscle mass just the arms so
that's why he's picked up the English
and the attrition is happy with that
and then of course with the key thing is
motivation keeping yourself going and
actually that message about marine
conservation about our oceans which are
seriously under threat is one of the key
things which is driving him on so rather
than it being a hindrance to him
actually that is probably going to be
the central motivator which keeps him
going
[Music]
it's fantastic you know when I did it I
had no cause I just wanted to go for a
long swim part of you that wishes it was
gonna be you stepping out on this piece
I'm real to see that it is Lewis I've
got some other swims in mind a problem I
have is that they're my dreams I can't
let them become my wife's nightmare I've
got a few more swim lessons in me to do
and I can't wait
just very quickly Greg and have we all
got that in us do you think yes is the
answer to that I think it's about
application really it's actually about
Drive I think what's great here is that
Lewis has got a cause and that causes
the really important course for all of
us and I think if you have that cause
and you have that drive and
determination
everybody can achieve something really
special he's a sleeper had my swimming
costume with me earlier the answer is No
Greg Whitehaven was lovely to have here
thank you very much indeed it's a truly
inspirational story for all of us as
we're leaving certainly and we'll see if
we have all got something like that in
us 30 more still to come
following Lewis's progress as he heads
towards the finish line just behind me
back in just a moment
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well welcome back to a cold windy and
wet Dover where we're here to witness
the end of Lewis pews long swim Mother
Nature has been trying to stop him
leaving him at the mercy of tithe and
jellyfish lots of them but his mission
to do right by it and help to protect
our oceans is nearly complete against
all the odds well I am here at the
finish line Shakespeare Beach in Dover
and as you can see he'll have a fight on
his hands with the weather as I
mentioned but I'll be meeting him when
he emerges from the waves for the final
time expecting him to get into the water
oh he's in the water rather he's in the
water but in about about five minutes
now and will follow every stroke of his
last room as he attempts to become the
first person to swim the 330 miles from
Land's End to Dover wearing just speedos
goggles and a hat those are the rules
well he has got 2.5 miles to go for
kilometres and it's all in the name of
saving our oceans he wants government to
protect at least 30% of them by 2030
from industrial fishing mining and
drilling and the Environment Secretary
Michael Gove is told Sky News that Lewis
has shown inspirational leadership and
grit well joining me now is the former
competitive swimmer Mark Foster but
first let's look back
back to shore after his penultimate swim
and Lewis Pugh has much to celebrate
he's swum 327 miles from Lands End and
Dover's now within reach the first
person to swim the length of the English
Channel he's taken half a million
strokes burnt ninety-eight thousand
calories and been stung by countless
jellyfish it's been incredibly tough a
few days credibly a tough few days oh
I'm mentally exhausted and physically
exhausted and emotionally exhausted the
team is exhausted we are all exhausted
but also excited or so excited
Dungeness started becoming a burden
every time you seem to suffer well is
this gonna be the final head-to-head
land which is going to stop me
and you know we threw out the charts and
we worked up all the different options
was I gonna go in short but then we're
close to a power station was I gonna go
further out sure but then we've got the
all the shipping coming up and down the
English Channel we didn't discount any
option even the option of swimming
across English Channel and swimming to
France Lewis has been swimming for a
cause better marine protection we went
to Goodwin Sands just off the Kent coast
a few days every month is exposed by the
spring tide and it's a conservation zone
because of its rare marine life
yet Dover Harbor has been given the
go-ahead to dredge three million tons of
sand for its construction work all the
creatures are in the sand and if you
start taking the top two meters off the
sand here it's going to have a huge
ecological impact on the whole area I
know we can't see it and our decide is
out of mind but they are there the port
says the sands are the most economic
source of material for its expansion and
has been given the go-ahead to start
dredging by the independent marine
regulator but lewis wants the government
to put the environment first a swim has
all been about trying to deliver a
message to the public about what's
happening to our oceans relief
excitement but that's really the
important thing at the important moment
because that this this long swim was not
about swimming it was not about trying
to become the first person to swim the
full length of the English Channel
it was about trying to deliver a message
one last push and Luis will be in Dover
after 105 out on sleep Thomas More Sky
News Dover well our science
correspondent Thomas Moore is the man
with the best view of all he is
following Lois please every stroke in a
support vessel and how far has he got do
you think he's that he's got this really
would make steady swimming style hasn't
- Thomas he has yeah he's probably done
about half a mile safe
[Music]
look at it go he's just very steady
progress in his making alongside the
support but the Agila there imagine what
he's having to do here this is a man
with tendinitis in his his left shoulder
it really hurts every time he lifts his
arm and that sends spasms all the way
down to the back
and yet he's having to keep going this
is real grit now that is going to see
him thousand strokes therapist and a
nutritionist a chef he's trying to keep
his body in the best possible condition
because every time he gets out after one
of these long swims his muscles are
screaming out they are breaking down and
normally
we have time to recover before going
again but to get back in that water do
it all over so there's an awful lot of
breakdown chemicals and flama tree
responses going on inside his body right
now he's still having to keep going it
hurts but he's still going well let me
also bring in while there thomas is
following Lewis Pugh former competitive
swimmer Mark Foster you have to hand it
to him what do what you notice about his
stroke there he's doing it obviously to
sustain for this endurance sport but
it's slow and steady wins the race in
this case yeah well it's just finding it
finding a rhythm really is you know
you're talking just you've said ten
kilometers a day every day he's not
going to go off with a massive leg kick
and bass it's just going to be it's all
arms and the slow tempo because he's got
to do air after hour after hour and I
just split was finding the rhythm I
don't know what he's feeding when he's
eating I'm seeing anything but yeah sort
of those things you think what wonder
what's going through to his mind is an
awful lot of time to think either
shouting out Thomas Moore will no doubt
report back in just a moment but he does
like to shout out thoughts sometimes to
write them down yeah I guess he wants to
share what's going on in his mind
because this is yes it's a it's a
challenge it's a massive challenge but
at the same time he's doing it for for a
cause so I mean that's the whole thing
is really it's doing it for some purpose
it's not been a it's a personal
challenge for this doing it for for the
greater good we'll just about the
environment and we talked earlier about
these steely sees we've got here maybe
gray you might call them and very murky
water to swim in you don't know what's
around you do not what's underneath it's
got used to it in his head for someone
like you who's spent your lifetime going
up and down a swimming pool it's a
completely different sense it's
completely different environment when he
spent his swimming is endurance swimming
of life in the open water so I guess is
he's very at home out there and I think
it's like anybody when you do anything
for the first time it's quite daunting
and the more you do it the more
comfortable you become I think it's it
looks very solitary out there but I
guess people have been in from from time
to time I can only see the pictures that
you can
it looks like he's going quite fast but
believe me is not it's a long slow plod
as you say it's not about how fast you
get them it's about getting there in the
end so yeah oh you won't be seeing the
bottom you won't be feeling anything I
think the things have been hitting him
every now and again maybe as we said
before jellyfish or fish but less so in
this pot of waters compared with her
down in the southwest certainly there
was a real problem a struggle to get
breathing right in rough seas he's
talked about having just a nanosecond to
decide when to breathe or else getting a
mouthful of water starting to choking
actually actually got on board his
support vessel and Sutter Devon met on
one occasion yeah Thomas Moore you heard
of me he's perhaps shouting out to you
and but his mood is certainly
single-minded and saying that the work
starts now in some respects did you hear
what he said to had to say no he has
been delivering a message to Michael
Gove and that is all about protection of
the Seas that what the government has
done so far he's not good enough
according to you know is that he wants
much tighter control
you take up the anything had to give to
the vast majority of UK's coastal waters
just an two square miles of ocean have a
total ban on fishing winning is really
pushing for much tighter control and
that is why he's pushing himself to
these limits
nobody include that voluntarily
16-channel that's the distance he's gone
been going along the way is that thought
that he can actually make a difference
here the marine protection around the
world but here in the UK and the English
Channel too
why of the headlands Thomas been so very
difficult because obviously Dungeness I
know you swam with him this weekend
what was that like for you because
they're not that one of the headlands of
Dungeness was yet another headland that
was difficult to get round why is that
it's because of the way the the currents
work in in the English Channel that as
the tides move over shallow and then
deeper water they can do some really
strange things so sometimes the the
tides just disappear altogether he calls
it a lazy sea and that's what happened
around Dungeness Peninsula going because
as you can see there he always swims on
this side of his support boat he
breathed to his right he can always see
the reassurance of the boat and even
skipper there and they talk to each
other on a regular basis so he he was
swimming unable to see the land and
occasionally he was taking a breath to
his left and that's when he would see
the niccola power station on the
Dungeness peninsula and it just didn't
seem to move and that was disheartening
but he didn't seem to make any progress
whatsoever and that's why I found it
really tough mentally to keep picking
himself up to go back and do it again
the next day knowing that it was going
to be just as tough and yet somehow he
had to make it round this headland if he
was gonna get the make it through today
whoa
yes and he's talked hasn't he about the
wrong sea state the wrong current the
wrong swell actually feels like he's
swimming uphill which must just be so
soul-destroying
what about your swim how far did you
manage and what did it feel like and I
did a kilometer with him so he's done
five hundred and thirty but it did give
me some inkling of what he has been up
against the seas were quite large then
the the skipper called it lumpy and when
I turned my head to breathe I wasn't
sure whether I'd be faced with a wave so
I'd be swallowing water rather than
gulping air and that was that was really
hard to keep going in those
circumstances because when she starts
swelling large amounts of
salt water not only are you choking but
you also start to feel sick quite
frankly and then it really does SAP your
energy very hard to keep going in those
conditions and if you look at the waters
now and the waves are nothing like what
I faced when I was swimming with him but
nevertheless they're coming straight on
to him so he's having to push his way
through the waves the whole time and
that will will certainly be slowing him
down little it's hard workers near even
now Thomas Moore thank you very much
indeed
well obviously a campaigning is
absolutely key to what Lewis Pugh is
about not far from here a campaign a
battle is underway right now ten miles
of sandbag known as you might notice
from my guests here Goodwin Sands so
let's bring in Joanna Thompson a Fiat
Punto thanks for joining us and tell me
about Goodwin Sands then first of all
why is it so important to protect to
protect it what direction is it in is it
that way and why do I protect this
sandbag well for numerous reasons I mean
historically it's really really I'm
significant that least over 2000
shipwrecks have been recorded there over
the past eight hundred years there's
military air crash sites there there's a
seal colony there's the newly hopefully
designated marine conservation zone and
it's a natural cedar fence for East Kent
for sure which is really vulnerable to
coastal flooding so these marine
protection zones but and Michael goes
plan and the government's plans started
in 2013 he announced some more didn t
yes back of World Oceans Day under
consultation right now
it was actually fully fledged as a court
as a concession zone or is it one of
those it's in in a phased it's the third
it kind of interface okay the problem
you've got is that right behind us or
right here is the Port of Dover and they
want to get some of the sand and gravel
from Goodwin Sands to expand the port
and that's your battle three million
factor that they want to take some the
good ones they're going to scalp the
sounds and look for scalping it they'll
be taking the wildlife the microflora
the micro fauna the bottom of the food
chain they'll also be potentially
dredging air crash sites and all the
historic archaeology that is based in
the sounds so for example blue mussel
beds they nip the seabed together they
provide habitat for other species very
easy to destroy things like that very
quickly they're very fragile Ross not
very pushy but there's a species called
Ross worms they create reefs and they're
essential to foundation of the sands if
they dredge it'll go down to rock bottom
they'll be popping and they take a long
time to recover let's give a long very
long time to recover so the David Port
Authority the harbor authorities here
saying that it's very nearby it's got a
low carbon footprint to get this stuff
it's already been approved by the
licensing authorities and actually it's
a very eco efficient way of getting
aggregates that they need to carry out
the world well this is but this is what
the whole islands it gets blue belt vs.
blue growth you know you've got to win
you've got to consider both of them and
Michael go to plant plan is absolutely
useless or worthless if a week after the
consultation period is finished so
dredging from an arrangement license
dredging is it's granted for the very
sand which that was one of the protected
features it just makes a complete
nonsense a mockery of the whole system
the carbon footprint argument is also
very very weak because by growing the
port's they will be increasing their own
we can't really say that one thing is
acceptable and one isn't
but we're in a situation where we've got
brexit coming up less than a year to go
you've got to get trade into Britain you
need a port this functioning it's very
old no doubt it needs rebuilding in
places and improving and expanding you
have to allow economies like this to
thrive in these places unless they do
but if you look at the map of the actual
area landfills created
for
well Michael Gove and his blue belt
he'll be coming down here fill it on
board you've got a list of questions no
he was a letter we want to give him not
to take up too much of his time yes so
the idea of the blue belt there's 50 of
these marine conservation zones they
started in 2013 another 41 going out for
consultation yeah and we're gonna try
and get a word with the boat a little
bit closer to Lewis to make it easier
for him and we'll try and get a question
to him to find out how the swims going
Lewis Lewis Lewis difficult to get him
to he'll hear us because of sensory
deprivation when he's in the water
Lewis okay skipper they can see because
he's turned towards her skipper and this
is exactly how I was saying earlier on
how the skipper and Lewis talked to each
other in regular basis and he's coming
over to us now he's going to interrupt
his long swim to have a little chat with
Sky News as he's coming along so if we
just slow down the boat make it easy for
Lewis because he can't keep going
otherwise this is just gonna move our
camera location this side just take care
of there Lewis around the props
there we go Lewis how's it going hi it's
a bit tough to slice a little back room
only good I think another two kilometres
now I know
so excited to finally get there to
finish this herb I've been dreaming of
this day but nearly fifty days to
finally see the White Cliffs of Dover
and over there is the end achieved now
to be this place when I started I wasn't
sure I could make it I really wasn't
sure and it's it's a dream you know
channel swimming is not a solo sport
there's been a whole my whole team there
Oh
thank you so much and there he goes once
again swimming on his way to Dover now
he's done 328 miles by my reckoning
almost there in Dover as he head so
along the white cliffs and as you heard
conditions are the best this morning but
you heard his spirit is high and that's
well get in through to the finishing
line just as the wind is picking up
blowing offshore he's gonna have to
contend with that if you're gonna be
able to walk up Shakespeare Beach I'm
really excited to say that we can see
you at the finishing line so finally we
can see the catamaran support vessel and
the boat that you're on as well so
finally for us here on Shakespeare Beach
and over Lewis Pugh you are in sight I'm
gonna tell you that which is brilliant
for him is earlier that we on the beach
now can begin to see him and and
effectively bring him in yeah sort of
gets to see that for the finishing line
so that must mean mentally that's one of
these things it's kind of oh I'm nearly
there and I know when he got in this
morning was about four or five K away
which doesn't seem an awful long way
when you've been going for 550
kilometres but it must be I was always
thinking about that at the beginning it
must have been this bars the start of a
journey and the middle parts that must
have been the calling hard part the
physical and the mental side of things
and now it's as much as his hurt and it
would be like I'm nearly there and this
is all over and then you can then
actually well let's bring in another of
my guests now from the Blumarine
foundation come round Clair and there
and join me and mark and Claire Brooke
here so why is something like this that
Lewis is doing so important to raise
awareness for things that you are
campaigning for well it's just fantastic
that he's doing this ambitious swim and
and drawing everyone's attention to the
crisis in our ocean because he's been
talking about the fact that on the way
he's hardly swamp-ass to any fish at all
we're basically emptying our oceans of
fish and that's you know terrible for
their ability not only to provide us
with food but also their function in
regulating their climate their obviously
doing it quite well today
regulating the jelly fish blooms one of
the reasons we have so many you know
that is that is an indicator species
isn't it tell me why exactly well larger
fish have jellyfish as their main diet
so for example a bluefin tuna will eat
on average 31 pounds of jellyfish a day
so if we take all the big fish out of
the sea then these other parts of the
ecosystem will start to thrive and
they're not always desirable there was
one moment when nearly midway through he
realized he had to do another night dive
and he had these neon bits attached to
him doesn't he like as if it was a party
as he dived in so that the support team
could see him they put the torches in
the water too so he could see what he
typed in filled with jellyfish
absolutely filled with jellyfish and
they had this debate about how many
times he could be stung to make it
acceptable for him to continue he got
him he managed eight minutes in there
and had to be pulled out absolutely
stumped pieces Vogons it's it's
incredible what he's put himself through
and we're we're kind of Anor of that and
you know all of us like the blue marine
foundation and all the other
environmental ngos are so grateful to
him for having put himself through this
well the man who makes the decisions the
environment is actually Michael Gove has
been with him as well saying that he is
an inspiration that he's trying wheel
grid what does Michael Gove need to do
to get the protection that we see on
land also in the seas because we're so
far behind don't we well we have a very
ambitious the government has a very
ambitious policy on marine protection
the UK has the fifth largest ocean
estate in the world we have 6.8 square
kilometers around the world around these
you know tiny little overseas
territories that is in our gift to
protect and we have this blue belt
policy and amazingly in these in a very
divided political times it's actually
something that is uniting a lot of MPs
we have 283 MPs have signed up to the
blue belt charter saying they want that
and that's from across all political
parties so there's a lot of wealth from
the people obviously from from all
politicians
and so all we have to do it's a bit like
Louis right now we've just have to push
it over the edge you know the policies
there its ambitious its visionary it
just needs to be a bit better
implemented and at the moment we're not
really doing that right and we're not
doing it in such a way either that these
marine protected areas or are effective
all that they're bringing benefits to
the overseas territories themselves has
been for the UK ones anyway that you're
you're protecting a specific species
from a specific activity it's not a roof
root and branch ecosystem habitat
protection and actually say for example
we've talked about the dredging here
nearby a Goodwin Sands and the
protection areas don't really do their
job is that a fair criticism do you
think it was actually right you have to
consider a whole ecosystem you can't
just protect one single species and
these marine ecosystems are
fantastically complex you know and they
inter rely and so you you have to think
about nature leading the way in these
marine conservation zones not just you
know one particular interest group you
know we've got these crazy situations
where you've got marine conservation
zones supposedly which are allowing the
Dutch electric pulse fishing fleet in
there basically electrocuting the entire
seabed you know that's not protection
that's meaningless and Lewis Pugh has
talked hasn't he as remember UN picture
of the oceans about industrial fishing
literally trawling the bottom out of the
seas let's listen again about why this
is so important to him I'm so I'm so
excited excited and relieved there's
been an enormous Lee long swim as you
say we'd be not here for 49 days we've
been at sea for 49 days no I also wasn't
sure when I when I started at Lands End
whether I would be able to make it you
know the world is divided between
pioneers and followers pioneers do not
know whether they're going to be
successful in in their quest
I hoped I prayed that I could do it I
did the training to do it but still it's
an awful long way and anything could
have happened over those 50 days
while Lewis Pugh is in the distance here
coming in to view in Shakespeare Beach
and if we could show you her a small
picture of him in the distance you have
to pee or maybe get your glasses on to
spot him but we can see him it's all
good and not long to go now Louis is our
message so yes okay well anyway Pierre
of that briefly while I talk to him so
the last the last stages for him 49 days
in so many calories consumed it doesn't
bear thinking about so much difficulty
that he's faced not least carrying these
injuries neck overcompensated back
you've probably been there yourself with
some of those injuries yes but he is a
very very short period of time to put
them lie again before he gets back in if
I've had an injury in the past your
managed on land in a physio room and
some of the time you don't get back in
the next day because it's it's not good
for your body so he'd get time to heal
where he every day has had to get back
in again and get on with it because he
can't get behind his schedule and also
set out fifty days so he had to be here
at 1:30 today to finish it so he's had a
goal and an end in sight and he's had to
stick to it I just say to the viewers at
home I'm sort of standing I'm a lot
talking live one single stroke but know
what he's done is it's quite incredible
I can't even imagine you know getting in
there for for one of the days that alone
fifty days non-stop but the bottom line
it's it's it's for a bigger cause even
heard from Blumarine foundation then
when you hear these stories and hear
what's going on in the oceans which we
don't see because it's beneath the
surface it's fascinating what we are
doing to a planet and that's the irony
isn't it that actually it wasn't until
we invented scuba diving in the late
20th century that we realized the
destruction that the Industrial
Revolution and current practices were
wreaking on the ocean so it's it's a
it's a new thing which is why we're so
late to the past in us in effect to
protect the marine environment so Louis
is excited about finishing let's hear
once again to him talking to Thomas More
just a few minutes ago I it's a big
tough to started
only good I think another two kilometres
now hello so excited to finally get
there to finish this sir but nearly 50
days to finally see the White Cliffs of
Dover I know there's the end Thomas when
I started I wasn't sure I could make it
I really wasn't sure and it's it's a
dream team there who helped me get here
and I'm so excited to just walk out
there beachner gonna punch through it
and try and get right in close to the
White Cliffs yes the White Cliffs are
firmly in view thanking his team there
they've all been cooped up on a support
vessel a catamaran close-quarters not
easy it has to be said logistics
extremely complicated their decision in
fact to go the south side of the Isle of
Wight because of marine traffic really
meant that they struggle to get into
marinas to pick up water they were
living off emergency supplies so you
forget this is an expedition really
there's so many things to think about
how nice to see him there so cheering
it's all about the support stock so yes
he's doing what he's doing and he's he's
pretty as I get in the water I do my
swimming and I get to be a spokesman
around the environment whereas the team
of people that I don't know the boat
nutritionists physio is but these other
people that enable him to do what you
set out to do so it's nice there's a
nice little thing that in terms of the
training that he's done
you know you perhaps us in Billerica in
Essex maybe he was born in Plymouth and
ended up living in Cape Town from a
young age but he's been training around
the Falkland Islands and the Cape of
Good Hope this is extraordinary places
to train for something like that I guess
that's the thing though what he knew it
was gonna be up against and obviously
clearly they knew what was ahead of him
and they researched very very thoroughly
so we're gonna put yourself in those
conditions and you need to prepare in
those conditions it's a little bit like
oh you know you know I'm I'm a speed
swimmer so therefore I need to teach my
body to go fast
he's an endurance swimmer so he needs to
get in there day in and day out and make
sure his body can deal with what is
going to ask it to do but and also in
those sort of conditions cuz otherwise
if he's gonna be swimming
nopal and then put himself in there it's
gonna be a huge shoe shop so it's sort
of going to some bad conditions in bad
weather whether it rain something make
an awful lot of difference when you in
the water but the wind and the waves and
the swell about the breathing you see so
you're looking there he'll get in and go
where's the swell coming from it's
coming from this sidewalk do you know
what I've breathed to the other side
otherwise I'm gonna take on an awful lot
of water not be able to breathe so you
look at the conditions you look at the
environment and you'll change
accordingly and he talked actually about
his tongue swelling actually because of
the salt water and the amount that he
had consumed so very difficult
conditions and so once again I say he
isn't shot on the beach our camera
doesn't show as closely as the eye can
see I have to say sir to me doesn't look
very far away at all but from our camera
he is a dot in the distance so bear with
us if you don't mind looking at tear at
our pictures of him in the distance but
certainly there are some people it is
him the crowds are building no doubt
some had been pulled up and in fact some
people have gone into the water which is
very supportive the tide is coming in
they've timed this haven't made to try
and get the use of the spring tides
which certainly pummel him along yes
sometimes he described taking one stroke
and the current taking him another
stroke and that's what they've been see
for seeking the spring tides have been a
real help for him
no we are look at that support I guess
you'd only go against nature do because
nature will win so let's try and use it
where possible so looking at the tides
every day high tide low tide and trying
to swim at the best opportunity rather
than had a conversation with a friend of
mine actually Greg white you said before
when he was on it was on earlier and he
said he's found the channel once and got
a mile away from France the tide turn he
sat there for six hours going no when
they pulled him out it was only a mile
offshore so yes they're trying to use
the environment to help him which
actually he's talking about the
environments is all about the
environment and those I'm guessing those
guys they're much soon back a little bit
and give me look the supports yes 30% of
people trying to swim the channel
actually fail within one mile so that's
why and the importance of channel
swimming rules which is the speed estar
shorts the goggles and
the yes that is it the jellyfish land of
Cornwall and Devon you certainly wanted
a bit of protection didn't you why have
we got those rules it's bonkers you'd
have to talk to someone from something a
shadow small Association I kind of okay
it makes it a level playing field and
what they're trying to do is make people
swim it in certain conditions which are
the hardest conditions I've got to say a
lot more people would make it in body
suits or own wetsuits I should say
because they they keep you warm and
pretty the most important thing they
keep you're boring you know you're not
gonna sink in them because they're
actually they actually got me float
better so they try make the conditions
very very hard and then I'm sure you
would love to bring a wetsuit every day
but I think the thing is he's
conditioned his body now and you saw
there when he was just sitting treading
water and chatting to your reporter
Thomas Thomas it seems clearly it's
quite a home in the water we didn't seem
cold we're standing here going but it's
cold
no this isn't cold and it's quite brutal
what he's doing so pretty seems to be
enjoying himself in polar regions the 12
degrees that he had round lizard point
and I have to confess I stood in a river
at as consistent 12 degrees this summer
a Gloucestershire and I screamed to get
out of the water 12 degrees is not
something I'm a very quick 12 degrees
around there's a point 14 not far from
here little bit warmer 8 up to 18
degrees so those are the sorts of
temperatures a little bit warmer than
anticipated know that when they're
getting a swim for when they're swimming
in a public pool it will be 28 degrees
29 degrees so it eats cold look at that
lips of Dover Lewis Pugh arriving Thomas
Moore
yes and he's he's moved in sure he's
hugging the cliffs there as you can see
the wind has really picked up and it's
blowing offshore so he should get some
shelter they're both from the the waves
and the wind they're trying to make
conditions slightly easier for himself
as he swims this this last stretch
towards Dover is not far to go now this
is 49 days at night 3 o'clock in the
morning when his body is screaming out
for sleep
[Applause]
[Music]
arrest to sleep because of the efforts
of the past few weeks and he can still
see him making steady progress very
repetitive arm stroke very steady arm
stroke lifting his arms well clear the
water because that is what a lot of open
water swimmers would do trying to make
sure they get their elbows nice and high
clear of the waves and reaching forwards
again pulling himself inch by inch
towards Shakespeare Beach and over now
Thomas Moore thank you very much indeed
well with me now I have Antoinette pew
Louis pews I was about to say
long-suffering wife but I don't think
that's how you feel about it and I know
you've been on board with him first of
all you must be extremely proud of your
husband I am very very proud also of his
team everybody's worked really really
hard to support him
the public is team friends even just me
being here my pet to rely on my my son
and brings to keep the homefront going
so yeah it's been a team effort and I'm
just really happy for Lewis sort of
coming to an end
did he really believe that this was
possible because he talks doesn't he
about how the world is divided into
pioneers and followers as a pioneer you
have so many sleepless nights because
you don't know that something is
achievable he is obviously a pioneer and
you did he really believed he could do
this yes and I'm glad that you bring up
the fact that he is a time
that is exactly what he does and who he
is and before expeditions they're always
ups and downs and and things change so
every day there's a new challenge and so
sometimes I'm sure there's a bit of
doubt that comes in but I've never had
any dancing here we see the point where
the starts don't we in mid-july
those balmy days of thought the heatwave
here in Britain but for Lewis and the
team and for you at home
this starts months if not years before
doesn't hurt yes I mean Lee he started a
good 10 years ago and finally you know
he's getting the recognition that he
deserves and yeah even for the for the
for the planning of this expedition it's
sort of all started last year already
it's probably seen two years and he's
got a lot of ideas that he malls around
him in his brain and he thinks about it
non-stop and then he comes after with
different aspects of what he wants to do
to to get the attention he's taking a
little rest isn't he treading water
every now and then and there's people in
the water out to support him yes feeling
the pain I was going to say but it's
probably warmer in the water than
outside on the day like this isn't it
has he had a lot of supporters has gone
through the 49 days yes absolutely and I
think that's really been spurring on and
it's been wonderful and even even at
home in Cape Town where we live
everything had people knocking on the
door and saying how Lewis doing and send
him our love and
well he obviously tweeted last night
that he thanked to you specifically for
the sacrifice that you and your family
have made I know he said before to get
back to his dogs at home well it's for
dogs at home [ __ ] cake - no doubt and
a lot of rescue what do you think he
will how will he feel at the end of this
cuz it's quite hard finishing a project
sometimes isn't it definitely and I
think I think you'll feel emotionally
and physically shattered and he'll
probably have to take it easy but still
do a little bit of training in between
to slow down after this because you
can't just stop everything and you'll
have to race those shoulders how
difficult has it been with the well
there specifically one of the shoulder
injuries he had but you know but he's
carrying a lot of pain now absolutely
and I mean it's repetitive strain injury
which I think one would have expected
and I think I think he's taking from top
to bottom so yeah I think wrist would be
a good option but I don't think he'll
risk for long if I know and this is the
longest anybody has ever swum in Channel
Swimming Association rules in these
temperatures I think that's right isn't
it nonetheless it's it's easel system a
Norwegian Ford that will do nothing
compared with this distance going to you
and that was protected neither side by
mountains this has been absolutely
battling the elements who would ever
think you want to go on the south side
of the Isle of Wight for example seems
to Mars out to sea sometimes 50
kilometers out to sea across the line
they can't see land
I mean it's mind-blowing isn't it really
it is and I think that's what also makes
it's different from the other
expeditions that has been every single
day
slot he just thanked his crew actually
and said it was the final push because
we can see him took me before the beach
now do you see uncertainly why is it
that somebody like Lewis Pugh can put
themselves through this I know he firmly
believes in the protection of the oceans
but some people just have the mentality
that they can do this she came from a
naval family this able to physically do
this and put his mind through it because
he's so passionate about what he's doing
and he loves the ocean and he he was
brought up that way as well to protect
what you love and
[Music]
and I thought he's got a very strong
mind once he's well Mark Foster you
heard
Antoinette they're saying that Lewis
Pugh has a has a very strong mind hello
this is one of our Olympians he's done
five Olympics and he was the fastest
person in Britain at the age of 15 so
another person who can genuinely swim a
very long way put it that way
maybe 150 meters those world record
holder 450 meters so this is a little
bit further more I did but as a kid I
did an awful lot and often an app also I
did a lot of our laps
was he a foolish enough before he was 17
he's had his first started having his
first swimming lesson
and I guess it's you started off in an
obsession with sort of look more to
swimming from an early age obsession but
he definitely has enjoyed the challenge
and being able to use it as a platform
to speak about what is truly and is
[Music]
and he has expressed his concern hasn't
he that he really hasn't seen enough
wildlife out there and then actually
what he is witnessed is why he is
campaigning then actually the evidence
he has seen himself now yes very sad
you're also very supportive I am I have
to sometimes do the silent support being
left at home for weeks on end which is
not much fun so that's fun I'm really
grateful that I was able to to come here
for a bit longer and and be part of it
he said early was sort of saying about
it's not just about him it's about the
team of people around them yes clearly
he's got the support network there but
you're a huge part of that - yeah how
are you going to occupy him when he gets
home and what treats have you got his
still because I hear from his chef he's
very into Battenberg cake and Victoria
sponge and I don't know if you'd like to
confirm that or not well I now have to
compete with Denise oh yeah yeah Denise
Wilson I think from Chester is that
right she's done a fine job cooped up
very small kitchen eight people have to
be fed how long were you on board for
and when did you are there is he stopped
a little bit again isn't he he's pacing
it so he arrives just on time probably
and how long we on boyfriend and we
therefore the Dungeness bit which was it
I was and that was pretty hectic because
we had to take a room art but couldn't
take the catamaran
art because of the weather even though
that we needed calm down so it was quite
a ride back quite hectic but just such a
relief to see the end of that place you
have to get past it yeah you could hear
the frustrations voice you just shouted
out again to the crew how long left
marked and really you know you put you
probably want to start powering in don't
you actually at this point yeah he's got
a lot of energy left in his arms
probably yes but at the same time as we
said it's not about the it's not being a
race it's
in a real journey for him and I think
the thing is now it's sort of I'm only
guessing I'm not I'm not his body or in
his mind but he must be really enjoying
this last bit because it's nearly over
as you say what state still for long
would it be out there again but this
must mean it must have been a long time
in the planning this right are you
involved in the process or you just used
it depends things change from day to day
so sometimes I don't know changes
sometimes I have to see on Facebook and
other because actually he was so tired
during this one that sometimes when I
did get to speak to him
all he could say was baby I'm really
tired I have to go to sleep and that was
quite difficult because he's generally
the problem solver for us at home knows
you're there yeah your voice is one
thing essentially you just seen a lot of
guys just some people getting in that
shifting against amount to Orton yes and
that's I mean we really are very near
here to the finish line up where you can
study yeah the boss you know the support
structure for the beach
but in the past he said my muscles are
aching Lee saw my tongue has swollen up
to chafe against my teeth from the
seawater and even coffee tastes so I
sold he's not really selling it to me I
have to say he lost his appetite but
Denis made sure that that changed at all
I used to swim and then I messed up my
shoulders in martial arts so I've
actually only just recently started
swimming again but I won't do more than
20 20 laps and that's all you've got in
any of them legs
I'm gonna turn you around there is your
husband swimming in I would say about
300 meters to go I don't know if you are
you feeling all right
I am I'm very holy together
I'm just so happy for everybody and
everybody that's been involved and I'm
just so happy but really support that
he's like everybody okay yeah well Louis
Pugh you really don't have very far to
go he'll be looking a twenty people are
now swimming with them anything that's
absolutely lovely I don't know who that
who you are but you've swum out to bring
him in and there's people on the beach
now all beginning to point all turning
around it's a horrific day down and over
the weather is it's British what can I
say it's absolutely horrible still
coming down here aren't they to support
him there's been a beach king going on
when the wind was whipping earlier there
are tin cans flying around bits of
tissue flying around it's exactly the
sorts of thing the Lewis's have it at
least a few a few moments there as he
pauses what will be going through his
head right now Antoinette as you know
him so well Battenberg possibly yeah
there's a lot of time to think about
that you've seen about message right
yeah I think there'll be a lot going
through his mind
it's probably about what I would have
said as you say a couple hundred meters
left but how many do you know that in
strokes is probably you know it might
sound not an awful lot but a couple
hundred strokes left when he's done so
many I'm just gonna pause this actually
let's listen to the chairs as Lewis but
you want to go up today go go go and see
how much thank you so much well done
anyway well done
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
IBM's going going hear me from here
you'd think they'd Kingson
Louis Louis
[Applause]
do that get loose
Louis
[Applause]
the world
[Applause]
[Applause]
yeah story mister
Luis Luis Luis come away from the shore
Stephen says come away from the shore
yeah
yeah there's a group as soon as they're
loose they've come to escort you in if
you swim towards the mate
[Applause]
yeah so Lewis is now swimming along the
edge of Shakespeare beach the beach
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
so we're right down on the beach
actually and Lois Pugh has gone a bit
early I have to say because the finish
line
he's really shallow now and the finish
line is about 150 yards down the beach
so we're walking now up to where he is
to try and grab a word with him because
he needs to go through the flags there
are specific rules to meet the channel
swimming Association and they have to
well one for is he has to touch the
harbour wall but he was told he has to
go through to specific flags which are
now quite a long way down there so we're
walking up to try and get to Lewis who
is swum to see the swimmers who've been
in the water patiently waiting for him
and the water temperature despite the
rain today is actually not that bad so
he had just four kilometres left today
330 miles 530 or so kilometers in total
that he's made and he is feeling
absolutely ecstatic that he's about to
finish it's quite a comedown though
finishing a huge endurance project like
this he'll have to keep some exercise up
you can't just stop and they'll
certainly need treatment on elements
like his shoulder which have been
extremely painful shot me if we lose
signal when you because we hadn't
planned to be this far up the beach
since a large group of swimmers now in
the water and plenty of people along the
beach they've been carrying out a beach
swim plenty of people now coming down to
see him because they followed his
progress for the last 49 days writing as
he has for Sky News on a blog talking
often about the difficulties that he's
faced not least the jelly fish blooms
the awkwardness of marine traffic this
is such a busy waterway of course and
even at one point military firing a
German vessel announced imminent firing
and they had to check that they weren't
within range so he's had to contend with
all sorts of human problems is it nice
to see him come in did you come down
specifically enjoyed the little pick and
also it's really inspirational for you
no doubt to see such an amazing
afternoon to something like those shorts
we could thank you very much I can hear
the cheers I listen to that
how'd you feel about cellulose to finish
is it nice to see him coming yeah
have you felt for him it's been hard
work has nerves you put your son down
yeah yeah we live locum so anything like
this where we're involved yet big cheers
of support now listen to that
[Music]
I'm Thomas what a reception he's getting
[Applause]
quite extraordinary pictures there of
Lewis Pugh being greeted after 530
kilometers as he makes these final
meters towards the finishing line he's
swimming along the very edge of
Shakespeare Beach at Shell 3 deepness
steeply here which is why he's actually
swimming in quite deep water there he
will be going the full length of the
beach and he will be touching the
harbour wall that is the the finishing
point of his swim clamber out onto
shakespeare Beach and he can finally
take a rest after 49 days five hundred
and thirty thousand strokes burning 98
thousand calories his body's screaming
but adrenalin you can see is keeping
those arms pumping Thomas I'm gonna wave
to you I'm just over here just the other
side of Lewis Pugh can you see me hello
there you are good to see you days at
sea for you as well I know as Louis
comes in it is quite amazing to see so
many people down here on Shakespeare
Beach isn't it I know many of those have
been doing a beach playing sadly all the
way along our coastline these days we
see an awful lot of plastic and when we
were down on Shakespeare Beach a couple
of days ago we did see
I'm to ensure that we have cease being
from drilling and so on
and that is what has motivates him all
the way along but right now it is a test
of endurance you can see him swimming
fast and that is walking pace that he is
something out you can see the people
behind it
given these
[Applause]
[Applause]
yeah it's fantastic is there they're
bobbing neon hats in the water brightly
colored for the open water swimmer
there's plenty of people here now who
are following up the beach like I am I
have to say the tide is coming in so we
have to be a little bit careful here let
me grab a few people what's it like to
see what do you like to see down here
[Music]
he's amazing amazing brilliant course
and it's just done so brilliantly
absolutely wonderful so free cheers to
him yeah well good that you've come down
on a day like this absolutely more
people should have come along fabulous I
think the weather might put some people
off it was awful earlier but are you
local to here do you see do you see
evidence of the plastics on the beach
that he talks about and lately and also
Dover council needs to stop dredging
good wins and throw the wildlife well
certainly that's a campaign that's
ongoing isn't it and Michael Gove will
no doubt be made aware of that as he's
brought down here certainly he needs to
take some action no just talking for
action thank you very much indeed tell
you what it's a race up the beach now to
keep Louis Pugh in sight we talked about
him swimming slowly I'm not so sure he
does now to be honest with you
you've come down to film louis p on your
camera have you today what's it like to
see him
Oh miss cool I shoulda been full of it
quite closely my little brother is a
first mate on on the earth well there we
are house he found it he's had a
brilliant time it's great experience
he's also he met some really cool people
and it's all for a good cause
is he was here into boating before was
this all quite new for him no so four
years ago now I thought oh there's a
boat we've been saying for years yeah
it's just something was just fortune no
they stumbled across the website yeah
it's been also really sorted I was aware
of before was he been so close to him
following it quite closely and it's
quite spirally I think I saw your
brother dive in the boat at one point is
that right were they celebrating the
halfway point yourself what it was oh
yeah I know exactly the photo you're
talking about some really key moments
for them the first hundred K the first
200 K the halfway point how important
has it been for the whole team to keep
those balls item and actually encourage
you to keep going and what's been such a
difficult endurance activity I think I
think it's important to set little goals
not little goals but it's important to
break up and set goals like that so I
have lots of small achievements so I see
equal one big difference well give us a
give a shoutout for your brother then
what's his name Rowan very proud yeah I
haven't seen him for sixty days now I
guess it's been yeah 49 49 yeah so yeah
we've come back to help sale you back to
Portsmouth because they'll receive on to
their next their next big thing yeah big
shout Rowan yeah
well well done first me and the team on
board it's hard work there isn't it
being cooped up in a team like that
really it's you know everyone's got to
muddle through because there's some
difficult moments where they're debating
whether or not to go in the water
but the currents are like what the sea
state is like very difficult right we're
very near the finish line what was your
name - Pierce your brother thank you
okay making your way to the finish line
now Thomas Moore is there on board hi
Thomas
you know you followed Lewis Pugh in the
Arctic
yeah sorry you've um you've followed
lips pure in the Arctic and doing this
the long swim fantastic to see Louis
coming in for the final few meters
[Music]
[Applause]
there are so many people who are
cheering now they're absolutely
delighted for him and they are so
supportive of his cause I'm breathless
Louis you swim too fast why are you
shouting out any moment now nice to see
him back yes no it's a long swim and
it's been a hard swim as well but it's
doing fantastic work criticizing plastic
in the oceans I'm wondering if he's
going all the way to the harbor wall
actually let's find out yes don't stop
in France definitely not is it good to
see him absolutely wonderful wonderful I
mean he doesn't even look tired I'm
amazing hasn't he done well he'll keep
moving through this young girls here too
there's a lot of children come down he's
gone all the way to the harbour wall
well you know Hayden Welch who we spoke
to earlier who had tried to do it
setting off from here and finishing at
Portland bill he kept reminding us to
remind Lewis that he had to touch the
harbour wall for Channel Swimming
Association rules and look he's going to
do just that
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
so he touched the harbor wall he turned
around and he swung me back were two
flags are waiting for him and a finish
line there reads the long swim
it's been a long swim it's been an
incredible feat of endurance but Lois
Pugh you're a record holder now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
lowest Pew congratulations can we be the
first to say you've done brilliantly
thank you how are you feeling right now
exhausted and accelerated in equal
measure it's not even easy to get up the
beach at the moment thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
Kelvin whoa whoa
Michael Gove is also here to see you
how fantastic for you that the
Environment Secretary comes down because
that's your core message isn't it that
something needs to be done yes I mean we
had a very constructive a very frank
discussion on the boats about the health
of the British oceans I've been swimming
now for nearly 50 days and what has
really shocked me is just how little I
have seen in terms of wildlife so lots
of jellyfish a few dolphins a few fish a
few birds but other than that very very
little we now really need to take the
health of our oceans very very seriously
and protect them fully so fully
protecting large sections of this
coastline but also around the world what
are you doing to your body putting
yourself through this yeah it's it's
been robust you know it's now being for
450 days my shoulders are absolutely
exhausted my whole team is exhausted
where we're here we made it when I
started out I didn't know whether it was
possible but we've made it well done
well done what was the hardest bit for
you I know you've talked in the past
about there are pioneers and there are
followers and if you're a pioneer you
have weeks of worry did the worry that
you had did that spell out into the
reality that you that you felt this was
a sort of two halves the beginning was
nice and easy and warm and flat once I'd
hit once I had hit the Isle of Wight
from that moment onwards it was storm
after storm after storm and getting
around Dungeness is one of the toughest
jobs I've ever had to undertake your
wife is here I know you wanted to see
her
[Music]
she brings you a towel well what will
you do now we all want to know because
it's very hard to wind down from a
project as big as this isn't it yes it
is but now the real work actually begins
I mean obviously I'm exhausted I'd like
to have a nice good rest and a great
very good sleep but very soon I go off
to the g7 summit the the the discussions
which are taking place a g7 summits are
about protecting our oceans that's going
to be a top of the agenda also then
we've got the high seas convention
coming up where all the nations the
world are coming together and saying how
can we protect the waters beyond our
national jurisdictions that's going to
involve a lot of hard work and a lot of
bridge building between the nations
congratulations your hard work begins I
have to say for me the jellyfish would
have put me off at the start you got
stung almost instantly but as a sign
you've said that's an indicator species
exactly what you're talking about
we found so many jellyfish all over the
place and what the jellyfish are telling
us well is that the oceans are warming
so they're an indication that the oceans
are warming because the climate change
but also because of overfishing yep
Michael go if you're there come and say
congratulations yourself come and say
here's the Environment Secretary coming
in to say congratulations - oh that's
lovely
a flag brought in as well I think news
is amazing I think he's a modern-day
hero I think everything that he's done
is just so inspirational I think the
long swim has really brought to
everyone's attention how important our
seas are and how important it all it is
for all of us do a bit to protect them
to restore them to health and to make
sure that this amazing environmental
resources there for future generations
and Lewis's courage his great his
amazing dedication I think is an example
to us all so what is your message to
environment secretaries like Michael
Gove
in the UK and elsewhere you're heading
off to New York obviously what do you
want to say well it's an opportunity now
for Britain really to leave at the
moment in terms of global leadership
there's a vacuum in terms of protecting
our oceans I think this is a natural
place for Britain to be in terms of
protecting our oceans not only here
around the UK but also our overseas
territories I'd like Michael to be going
to the g7 summit and showing the other
g7 nations and also in to the United
Nations that we talked the talk that we
know when it comes to ocean protection
we do the job it's very very difficult
for us to be encouraging other nations
to to do the same thing if we and
Britain are not leading Lucis right
we've already taken some steps to
protect the waters around around this
country but there is more that we need
to do and there's more that we also need
to do in order to to galvanize a global
coalition in order to make sure that our
oceans are purged of plastic but more
broadly that we also have more protected
areas in which we we stop the
exploitation of our seas and allow
nature to recover but we only have three
fully non exploitable parts of the UK
water don't we bloody Island and a small
part of Yorkshire only three it's not
really doing anything is it more needs
to be done you're right that more needs
to be done we've already said that there
will be more marine protected areas and
more marine conservation zones around
the do it you convinced that's actually
the point cuz sometimes George
predicting one species from one specific
activity in a small area you need to
protect the whole ecosystem and the
whole habitat I think there's always got
to be a balance which is struck in order
to make sure that coastal communities
can continue to fish but in a
sustainable way and one of the lessons
of Lewis's swim is that we will only
ensure that we have fishing industry in
the future if we make sure that we have
sustainable resources now and it's
striking that balance which it's
important we all do and we have to do
globally we have to recognize that there
are some parts of our seas and oceans
which need to be completely protected
which should be no take zones there are
other areas where the right sort of
fishing can carry on provided it's
sustainable and environmentally sensible
we've seen scalloped walls while you've
been in the water
they've been battles off the coast of
Normandy fighting over the scraps of
what's left of the scallop industry
and these are fishermen being attacked
British fishermen being attacked it's
exactly what you're talking about it's a
very very interesting thing you know
Desmond Tutu always says when we damage
the environment we create conditions
ripe for conflict and so so many of the
conflicts which are taking place around
the world today by taking place as a
result of of conflict over limited
resources and he also says that when we
protect the environment we foster peace
so when I see images of British
fishermen and French fishermen fighting
I think to myself we really have to do
absolutely everything now to protect the
environment to avoid this type of
conflict with our neighbors here in
France it's a real concern for the
government to see stuff like that as
well isn't it it's deeply concerning my
heart goes out to all the fishermen
who've been caught up in this as you
know and I'm from a fishing background
myself and I do have enormous sympathy
and I think it's important that we as we
are doing talk to the French government
make sure that those fishermen who are
fishing legally are protected as they go
about their work and we also need to
make sure that in the future we've got
the right regime in order to ensure
exactly as Lewis says that we have
healthy and sustainable resources for
for the future we're talking about the
politics of scallop fishing and here you
are not even feeling the cold that you
need to go and get what's your favorite
food well it's range so I started on
chocolate and then then it was potatoes
and for the last I don't know four weeks
it's been hot cross buns hot cross buns
and it's not even Easter I think we need
to get you a hot cross bun Lewis Pugh
it's amazing to to see what you've done
I have to say you'd have lost me on
jumping in I think we can all probably
say that none of us would really like to
do that but how do you feel about having
finally completed what has been a
long-held goal of yours to swim the
English Channel and become a record
breaker it's an absolute relief we're
just remembering this wasn't about
breaking records this was this was not
about swimming this was about trying to
convey a message to people here around
the UK that we have a very very precious
resource and that we must protect it for
not only our generation but most
importantly for future generation and
also for the animal kingdom how did he
do everyone what do you think
[Applause]
wants to say hello
let's just watch Michael go thank you
very much indeed for your time everybody
wants a photo now Louis everybody wants
to come and congratulate him there he is
with Hayden Welsh the man who didn't
quite make it how do you feel now Hayden
have you seen you know what there's a
lot of salt water out there but I got a
lot more in my eyes right now I think
are you feeling a little bit emotional
to see this it was wonderful to see it
finished
it's an emotional no doubt for his
family as well gaping Welsh I know
you've got about halfway didn't you yeah
I got about halfway yeah will you have
another go yourself to not doing this
channel but there are others out there
others out there for Lewis Pugh too no
doubt he's done the polar extremes
hasn't he he swum the Norwegian fjords
I want his towel as you can see and
you've been swimming - yes I'm a coach
for Channel swimmers here in in debt in
Dover so we are here all the time
swimming and as a coach for Channel
swimmers how do you feel about what's
what he's achieved it's the most awesome
thing one he's campaigning for a
fantastic cause we got far too much
pollution in our oceans and epic journey
this is history we're here in the middle
of history it's fantastic and I
understand that 30% of channel swimmers
finish with one kilometre to go is that
right yeah and if the tides and the
currents that make it difficult when
swimmers are coming in to cap Rene
there's a terrible tide that they go
through and it's really very very
difficult to cross there a lot of them
give up at that point because of the
tides and they're really exhausted this
gentleman that actually had a go he's
just been out in the channel he's
autistic
hello yes quite right I care really
deeply about the trees in the Amazon
rainforest and even the British forests
are very much and I don't like to see
plastic polluting our oceans I'm very
passionate about that and I also care
for the best that Jeremy Corbyn wins the
next generation but I won't you did it
already well good luck to you I hope you
manage to finish it one day
congratulations the world needs to be a
better place and that's all that matters
absolutely couldn't agree with you more
Marc Foster is here
British Olympic swimmer world-record
holder at a number of distances but not
330 miles and I'm now I'm gonna be not a
record holder an umbrella holder just
for you it's too late for me yeah no I
mean let's not be blown away by what
he's done but also everybody coming out
and supporting and also by him lewis
doing what he's done this challenge
today it's highlighting what a serious
problem were is so without him doing
what he's done we don't get and it's all
about the nipple once it's on it hello
you've come out to see have you hi did
you want to come and see Lewis yeah we
um we can sign it ourselves so we won
the ocean to be clean and we totally
support what he's done it's quite long
swim and it is all about inspiring the
young people Lewis Pugh talks about
everybody being a multiplier one person
tells one person another person tells
another person and it is all about
getting young children to understand
from an early age isn't it yeah because
it's their future at the end of the day
that we're ruining between the beaches
I know plastic toys they're attractive
aren't they it's very difficult sword
work isn't it um certainly this is all
about the campaign very important to
have a goal one he had to finish it - he
wanted his message to get out there and
seeing the people down here the
Environment Secretary as well who we
called over to talk to him - he's doing
just that his name yes let's just hope
it does make a difference
I mean clearly it's highlighted it but
then it's up to us it's up to
governments to actually do something
about it
so yes it's done but now that now the
real effort starts and we say this every
time and nothing seems to change so
something this is change and all of us
you know many children on their summer
holidays right now they'll go on holiday
perhaps swim in the sea none of us can
conceive of doing that I mean maybe you
can cuz you're a swimmer no I couldn't
even begin to understand what he's put
himself through no thing is amazing the
human body the human spirit isn't it
when you set your mind on doing
something and can anyone do it
absolutely not but then people do do it
and I think the thing is people only do
do it once this out
to achieve something and these his
achievement is his personal achievement
but the bigger picture here is every day
when he's been getting in and out is
highlights and the problems that we do
have so human beings I love watching
people go past in all their swimming
trunks actually let's be honest about a
lot of people talking about bear
swimming the channel one ladies swimming
the channel tomorrow that's got one Lake
and another guy who's going to swim at
the weekend so no he's inspiring a lot
of a lot of people to do amazing things
and I think here with me now is also
farming is that right
so Auto Fanning is another record holder
if the oldest man to swim the channel at
the age of 73 and is planning to do it
again at the age of 77 77 will well done
you and I know that you're very close to
Lewis Pugh that he became you became a
bit of a father figure to him after his
father died when he was 18 the first
time we swam together for happens from
now and then we did the channel for the
first time both of us so we have a long
association and I'm a great admirer of
you do you feel a bit like a proud dad
today I think as someone who has from
the channel the oldest person to ever
swim the channel I know who did it to
show what people over the age of seventy
could do you didn't necessarily do it
for any other reasons no I'm not a
record man but I'm trying to show in my
profession that people if you look after
yourself you can do things that people
don't expect and I think it's very
important so you've managed to swim the
21 miles of the channel he's done 330
miles
it's just it's been almost beyond quite
a bit with him I was on the boat so I
was allowed to swim behind him and sort
of and stayed on the boat it was a
fantastic experience really wonderful
but he's driven I mean he is one of
those very very exceptional people who
doesn't matter what the odds are he
finds a way so I think we're very
fortunate to campaigning for what he is
do and the way was hard wasn't it you
know you talk about the jellyfish the
tides the marine traffic the current
helping or hindering felt like summing
up he'll also make downhill the sea
state I mean all of it was thrown at him
very much sir but he had a simple data
most remarkable crew of people
photographers biases you have to give a
shout out for the team because the
logistics to something like this are not
easy are they to mend ously difficult
and then to have 10 people living on a
boat in a very small confined person
keeping peace that's something 50 days
imagine it okay panting thank you very
much Neil what are you planning to do
your next go by the way that's the
secret okay might you be 78 when you try
it I hope not
we wish you the very best of luck Otto
Fanning who currently is the oldest
person to swim the channel at the age of
73 and is planning to do it again just a
quick word from people here how do you
all feel that he did
I was a motor yesterday were you how
come
yeah well you invited me on board as
recent does he know years yeah each
others from her in 1960 and 1966
represent each others from an
association invited myself and another
guy had keep going along for the ride so
discreet it was terrific terrific and so
you know as much as he as he does how
hard is to swim an open water like this
and genuine open water you know 50
kilometers out to sea across line B for
example no land in sight
Oh 30 miles from land across the line by
yeah but that's rough and tough out
there because you get a tease and that
was a good reason as what but he was up
for it it was up for the job man
Mountain is no man Mountain there we are
Lewis whew man Mountain the human polar
bear you know but that's actually almost
literally true isn't it
swimming in the Arctic and the Antarctic
movies done that's how we achieve that
victory the human polar bear and driven
on by the message warm boffin I know
didn't they say was about 18 degrees I
think 12 degrees off lizard point would
have had me done I think probably I'll
give you a sense of the global warming
right when I swam the channel in 1960 it
was 58 this is 63 64 there's a
difference and did I read that there's
only two thousand three hundred and
thirty one people who have ever swam the
terminal tunnels are sad about right run
the channel tunnel the channel I'll rush
off and do that I'm in the first on a
day like this it might be possible I
don't have more people climb Mount
Everest was from the English Channel
Channel I read that good luck well done
thank you very much indeed I'm glad you
joined him on board yesterday more
people have climbed Mount Everest well
there we are maybe not now they might be
inspired so
Louis pure he's in the distance now
giving other interviews he's come onto
dry land day 49 he managed to achieve
what some had deemed the impossible
within his timeframe of 50 days he is
the only person BAPS will only be the
only person to ever swim the full length
of the English Channel starting off
there in Cornwall across all those
difficult headlands lizard pulling the
first one
Dungeness nearly got him off the coast
of Kent but he has made it landing here
on Shakespeare Beach in Dover Lewis Pugh
the long swim for you is over now it's
time for rest let's look at some of his
best bets
[Music]
the world is divided between pioneers
and followers pioneers do not know
whether they're going to be successful
in their quest
I hoped I prayed that I could do